people are more motivated by love than
they are fear but most of the world
sells fear so stop selling fear to
yourself you're not going to work harder
cuz you're saying you're a piece of [__]
fear and negativity is a shortterm
motivator love and compassion is a
forever game attention is the number one
asset look I got incredibly fortunate I
I think I have a world-class mother who
you know I was born in the Soviet Union
that was a very challenging place to
live my mom unlike most the people from
that part of the world was an optimist
people really struggled in that Society
from 1917 to the time it fell in 1989
and I don't have to tell this audience
Russia is not the easiest place to live
even right now um and so I'm incredibly
grateful because I think a lot of us in
this audience to succeed with emotional
intelligence we either have to get very
fortunate and get the luck of the draw
of DNA and parenting or we have to put
in a lot of work in meditation therapy
and living life and so for me I you know
a lot of times people say a lot of
people that live the life that I lived
which is worked a lot and worked really
hard and worked hard smart and people
throw lucky at them right they got lucky
and a lot of people that in the audience
and their parents and me that have put
in the work you get triggered right
you're like man I work so hard this
isn't luck you you're not working or you
know you don't get it but I I will say I
got lucky when we talk about emotional
intelligence I do I did get great DNA I
have two siblings who have different DNA
than I do and not that mine's better or
worse than theirs it's just that I'm a
default Optimist and I believe that if
you're a default Optimist especially if
you're built like me where you're also
grounded in reality and it's not
delusion that if you're a practical
Optimist you're halfway home and then
I've also had the luxury of like liking
people spending a lot of time with
people managing people since I was like
14 15 you know when I was 16 I was the
son of the guy who owned the liquor
store and so by de facto I was managing
people at 16 and so here I am 31 years
later you know I have an organization
with 2,000 employees I have a very
public Persona and I interact with
people at scale and you know life has
become very obvious to me I believe that
plenty of people can make money and
plenty of people are not good at it but
there's really no correlation when it
comes to joy and happiness and being
content to how much money one makes and
I love entrepreneurship and I love being
a businessman and I love being a
competitor and I love grinding and
competing and tenacity and determination
but I like being happier than all those
things and uh you know I guess from my
standpoint I was self-aware at a young
age I knew myself I was willing to be
ridiculed cuz I had self-confidence and
for everybody in the audience what I
mean by ridiculed is I'm 47 so when you
were getting D's and Fs in school in the
80s and '90s you were going to be a
garbage man you weren't going to be
anything it's not like it's not the
world we live in now where
entrepreneurship is a viable if not over
Rock starred capacity and and occupation
when I was growing up the word barely
had any traction and so I got used to
losing early on I was able to build very
thick skin I'm empathetic to judgment
instead of crippled by it I think it's
powerful and you honestly I've become
incredibly motivated over the last
decade to talk about these things and
you know for the people in the audience
that are aware of my content I speak a
lot about emotional stuff in the
framework of marketing and tactics and
business and I'm proud of it because I
think it helps people and that feels
good when you think about you know
everything that you've been able to
accomplish in your life that we have a
lot of entrepreneurs in the audience a
lot of people working on their own
businesses and they often look to you
and they look to people to think about
what they want to do and kind of what
that success will be like in the end so
you lose sight of the process how
important do you think the process is
and do you think the current generation
of entrepreneurs are a little too
focused on the money that's going to
come down the
line yeah I mean you obviously have a
good sense of like the things that are
running through my mind you know I'm
obsessed with the process I I genuinely
love entrepreneurship so much that I
weirdly like to lose and I like to lose
because I respect the game more than the
stuff that the game can buy for me so
yeah do I think but but you know it's
interesting when you ask like the thing
that I hear there is I think
entrepreneurship became cool and I'm the
beneficiary of that but I think 20 years
ago a lot of the people in the audience
would have not been entrepreneurs but I
would have been and I don't say that as
a Raz or a dig to the audience I just
think that what I really want for
everyone in the audience is not to be an
entrepreneur and I do have fear that
some of the people in the audience are
doing the entrepreneur thing cuz it's
cool cuz it looks good on paper it's
cool to say you are and why I fear that
is not because they won't be successful
though that stinks and it's stinks to
lose it's that if you're not an
entrepreneur like really actually like a
pure
bread losing in front of your family
relatives will probably be scary because
really one of the telltale signs of a
true entrepreneur is their incredible
capacity to fail at least in the micro
and so you know I think I do think you
know look I mean one of the biggest
reasons I never show you know I I fly
private sometimes my time's valuable but
the reason I like desper desperately
never want to show that is because I
don't understand the glamorization of
jewelry or cars or flights because I
don't think that that is the healthy
part of the game I actually think when
entrepreneurs post that stuff I don't
think that's entrepre that that's
aspirational I really don't I actually
think if you look carefully it's making
a lot of people in this audience and in
the world feel bad about themselves
right they see all these people like
they fomo they it triggers their
insecurity and so I do worry about you
know as such a capitalist I do worry
about the over capitalization of the
content but that's always been the case
long before social media people bought
Mercedes and Chanel bags and moved to
90210 just for the validation there are
people in the world you know this who
send their kids to certain schools for
their own
selfworth and I I worry about that I
don't like that I think you should be
doing things for yourself and your
family out of the process not the stuff
because I think you'll be happier
mentally and you won't burn out and I
think that's
important I I think a big theme of what
you were just describing is when we live
our lives trying to prove something to
others or show that we're feeling a
certain way or we're living this life so
that other people think we're successful
and we did it and I think a lot of
people in this room would be afraid of
posting that video that their friends
might make fun of or their aunts might
think is silly and they should get a
quote real job so how have you kind of
blocked out the noise of other people's
opinions when you fail or you lose
because I think a lot of people myself
included you know need that
advice I got fortunate I um I lived in a
cocoon of an immigrant family where like
having a roof over your head and having
clothes was like and food was like a
huge win both of my parents did not care
about other people's opinions they
didn't flash they didn't need to go buy
something expensive so that became a
framework I also got very lucky that I
was so loved and my happy my house was
so happy because of my mom when we were
super poor when we came to America so I
learned at a very young age that money
and stuff did not bring happiness so I
never I I was built for it I was trained
for it and then I practiced it you know
I think in high school instead of going
to the cool party on a Friday night I
decided to do a baseball card show and
sell cards because I was an entrepreneur
I love the process more than you know
playing spin the bottle though that was
cool and I wanted to do that at 15 I
really just wanted to be an entrepreneur
and so I've always I've always had a
cocoon and it just has cons continued to
accelerate and this is why I talk a lot
about this I it's crazy when you realize
the prettiest girls in your high school
the richest guys in the world right now
how insecure they are right how like how
much everything they do is to impress
others that they don't even know um and
I get it like your parent you know your
dad never loved you the the way you want
it and you want to stick it to them or
the girl broke your heart and you want
to make a ton of money to prove to her
you know like I get it and you don't why
I get it and you'll laugh given our
connection I actually understand the
rest of the world predominantly through
the lens of being a football
fan and I mean this the only place I
envy like I genuinely hate New England
Patriot
fans and I mean that and I know like I
heard the laughs and I appreciate it but
I'm but I'm I'm I'm going to be
incredibly transparent and like give you
an Insight so much of what makes me
understand the balanced world is my
complete irrational of being a New York
Jets fan and knowing what envy and
jealousy and I'm hurt so I want you hurt
I'm completely inappropriate at football
games you should have seen me yelling at
Taylor Swift from the seats last have to
talk about that as a Swifty I mean like
I get it like it's incredibly
challenging to be jealous and hurt and
not feel in control all things I feel is
a jet band None of the things I feel in
life so I love everyone from a race and
gender and religion and income level and
part of the world standpoint in real
life cuz I'm fulfilled I'm happy I'm at
peace it's simple I don't and I do you
know how excited I get when people
outperform me in my own industries of
course I'm competitive and I'd like to
win but I don't hate I don't tear down
others but in football I do in football
I'm and and and because I feel that to
the core of my soul it makes me realize
oh my God I do this in this silly Arena
known as the NFL this is how the world
is living their lives there are people
who actually hate hate other people
because they see politics differently
that blows my mind or for the people in
the room they hate people that are
successful in a business that they're in
cuz they're better than them at it I
don't I don't want that for anybody here
because I only have to be angry for 4
hours every Sunday for four months a
Year everybody else here is doing that
365 days a year for their life and I
don't like
that so I
think there is a lot
there and I feel like where I'd love to
take it is when we think about those
people who it's not just you know their
favorite NFL team it's year round it's
the Envy it's the not good enough the
victim mentality something you talk a
lot about is gratitude how you're so
rooted in gratitude you so grateful and
that gives you that default optimistic
lens but I think all of us here we know
right three things you're grateful for
in the morning this is what gratitude is
we try but then after 3 days we stop
doing it right so how do you really live
and breathe gratitude every day and how
can we do the same do you know that I
never write down three things I'm
grateful for I don't meditate on it I do
nothing like that I just do it every
second of my life do you know that
multiple times a day I will think about
things that are challenging that I hope
don't happen like getting a phone call
that someone I love had a stroke that
someone I love is diagnosed with a
disease that someone I love suddenly
died in a car accident because these are
real things that happen to real
people I also struggle with complete
delusion do you understand that everyone
in this audience lives a remarkable life
in comparison to the 8 billion people on
Earth do you know that 735 million
people on earth almost 10% do not have
access to clean water clean water like I
don't know there's some water like do
you like like like the jacket you're
wearing the Hat this a $40 hat well it's
from Express it's not but but no but you
know what's so amazing about that right
like think about this like the fact that
you want a Friday evening afternoon are
able to watch this or be in the audience
like I don't think people understand and
I don't expect people to understand I
know I got lucky in being born in one of
the most horrible places in the world I
know I got lucky by living with eight
family members in a studio apartment for
multiple years I know I got lucky that
my parents basically didn't buy me toys
because that's not what we spent our
money on I know that I'm hungry because
I wasn't fed I know that I'm not
entitled I know but for everyone who's
listening you have to go through the
work on the flip side I grew up not
eating healthy not being told that
that's important not working out and at
38 years old I changed that and for the
last 10 years I put in the work for
something that didn't come natural I
also grew up with a mom that's the
sweetest but she lacked cander which
meant I lacked cander and cander has
been disproportionally My Kryptonite in
my professional and personal career and
that I can go backwards and tell you
everything that has not worked for me in
the last 25 years and I can tell you
immediately that the seed of that not
working out was my inability to deliver
cander to somebody which led to
resentment on my end or me being sloppy
and them not respecting me for my lack
of cander so and I know I've worked on
that the last four or five years after a
lot of pain professionally and
personally so I would argue though I can
understand that people in the audience
can't do gratitude the way I can that
I've worked very hard I know that people
have put in the work to work on their
alcoholism they've put in the work to
work on their depression and I just
challenge everybody here to not just say
well it doesn't come natural to me like
work on gratitude and the way you work
on gratitude is if writing it down three
times in the morning works well then
actually do it every day not for two
weeks January 1st to the 13th and then
give up like work is work and and if and
if you're unhappy and you've got some
money go go to therapy and if you don't
have money go start listening to more
positivity go take a walk work on your
head like you are accountable you are
capable don't blame the president don't
blame your grandma don't blame your mom
don't blame the mayor blame yourself and
don't blame yourself like I suck and and
beat yourself up have compassion to you
that this is my
circumstance but I can fix it and all of
this stuff bringing it B to the ground
instead of the clouds that I'm in right
now
all of this stuff has a direct
correlation of you being a good founder
and
CEO cuz it's hard and the real issue is
who you are when it's hard is the whole
game because your team doesn't need a
leader that is nice when it's good but
then when you lose a big account or
something goes bad you're yelling and
screaming and scaring everyone a real
leader is best when it's worse
I love that recognizing privilege having
perspective yeah also important I heard
some claps it's amazing that's why G's
the best he's straight to the point but
listen I want to also show compassion I
hate that we've weaponized words
privilege I promise you everyone in
America is privileged at some level like
you can look at privilege from a lot of
angles do you know that I believe that
if you were born into extreme wealth
you're less
privileged I I've heard you say this
will you expand on it to the audience I
think it's super fascinating yes I think
people have weaponized privilege and I
don't want people to feel bad that are
sitting in the audience who happen to be
fortunate enough that their parents or
grandparents have done well like I don't
view that as privilege I believe that if
you are second or third generation
wealthy and you're a purebred
entrepreneur you're in a very curious
spot because no one's ever going to give
you credit cuz everyone's always going
to say mommy and daddy put you on that
stinks I think we we need to stop
weaponizing things stop judging
everybody like everybody's got something
I promise you everybody's got something
instead of judgment and envy and
jealousy why don't we all lean into
compassion sympathy and empathy and
understand that everybody's got
something the amount of people that come
up to me and just assume my life is good
cuz I have a blue check mark and some
followers and a couple of dollars get
the [__] out of
here so
I love that you're bringing up
self-compassion sometimes with
entrepreneurship there can be this m
mentality I'm going to push myself I'm
going to tell myself I suck to motivate
myself to achieve what's the balance how
do you be nice to yourself but also be
the best at your craft love yourself is
a default that everybody should work on
every minute there it should be
non-negotiable and then as far as you
know motivating yourself look this goes
back to what I touched on earlier people
people are more motivated by love than
they are fear but most of the world
sells
fear so stop selling fear to yourself
you're not going to work harder because
you're saying you're a piece of
[__] if you're sitting there and I suck
you're not going to I promise you fear
and negativity is a
shortterm
motivator love and compassion is a
forever game and you can either believe
me or not but I promise you that you
know what I love you know what I love
somebody said something to me the other
day and said they said Gary that's toxic
positivity and I sat there and I I
laughed I said man the world is so
infatuated in pushing negativity they've
created this term just to demonize
positive
people and I laughed and and we had this
discussion it was a very civil I I you
know I actually genuinely enjoy people
that don't agree with me meaning because
I don't default into thinking I'm right
you want to be really happy fall in love
with the humble side of your life no
matter how much success you have it
keeps you in check and I enjoy the
humble part of myself just as much as I
enjoy my competitive conviction side so
we had this nice discussion and we it
was really a mental chess game very
bright person we were going back and
forth and finally I said to this
individual I said you know what's funny
I said we can have this incredibly
interesting conversation for the next 50
years of our life I said but there's one
problem and the person said what's that
I said I've already won and of course
you know that was like the point of like
this mental chess we were playing and
the person said what do you mean with a
smirk trying to see what point I was
trying to make I said well life is how
you see it you've already decided to be
a cynic and I've already decided to be
an optimist you've already
lost absolutely love it Gary just fact
fact
no but but to the point right for the
audience like to like go a little
further cuz I know I left it on a little
bit of like Simplicity if you decide
that the world sucks the world
sucks if you decideed you suck you suck
in the same way that if you decide the
world is good it's good I wish all of
you could see my uh Instagram feed and
Tik Tok feed it's like kittens kissing
each other it's like sunshine touching
your Grandma's Soul it's like like like
it's [__] positive and everyone's
like the algorith like the algorithm is
exposing
you I wish I could take everybody's
Instagram explore page and open it right
now I could tell you everything about
you lastly Gary you mentioned your love
of the Jets would you share the reason
that you fell in love with the Jets in
the
beginning oh you're trying to go there
for me
um it's a very special story I was an
immigrant like I said I moved to Edison
New Jersey I was 6 going on 7 I was
outside you know what's the makeup of
the crowd what's the age group what's
the range we've got a great mix we've
got we've got college students we've got
young adults old adults we're rocking in
here all right so can can the 40 and
older Make Some
Noise all right so for all these ogs you
guys know this for the kids in there
first of all I love you I'm a big
proponent of the kids I hate all this
jenzy bashing I want to bash the Boomers
um
but for the 40-year-olds that just made
noise the kids in here won't understand
in the80s we went outside and
played and so in 1982 right before I
started first grade I went outside to
play and this is how we played kids in
the room you'd actually go outside and
you had no idea what was going to
happen so I went outside and I looked
for kids like literally looked for kids
and I and I saw some kids playing
football with a Nerf football and I
walked over I just started really
speaking English even right and these
kids took me in as a crew they're like
What's your name and like they were very
warm to me which really meant a lot to
me as you can imagine just moving to a
new town and they're like you know who
do you like in football I was like
they're like well we're jet bands you're
a jet band which to be honest the more I
think about this story if those [__]
would just said giant I had four Super
Bowls and be's so
happy but anyway Eric Godfrey Robbie
turnick that crew they're like you're a
Jets fan that was 1982 the Jets had one
of their best seasons ever they got to
the game before the Super Bowl I thought
I hit I'm like oh this is good and
little did I know but nonetheless they
all had Jets
jerseys and I wanted one and I asked my
mom for one and she's like no way Jose
like that's not what we do in immigrant
life we don't buy $20 shirts like your
whole wardrobe is like $6 from
Kmart and
so I was sad and wanted one and at night
my mom spent the next 3 weeks knitting
me a Jets
Jersey which is my prize possession I
still have it and it has the number five
on how many people here consume my
content can you make some
noise so some of you are probably aware
you see me do this all the time when I
take a photo and I do that as a head nod
to my mom who's my hero and who's the
foundation of everything that I have
that is good and it's because she
knitted me a jersey and put the number
five on it cuz that was my favorite
number and that Jersey is the most near
and dear thing to my heart and somewhere
around five or six or seven years later
when I was 10 11 12 I decided that I
wanted to buy the New York Jets when I
got older and somewhere about 5 to six
or seven years later I realized how
important that Jersey was to me and I
have this great dream to buy the New
York Jets and one day build a stadium
and put that jersey in the front so that
every single fan has to walk by it and I
wanted the plaque to say from not being
able to buy a Jersey to owning the whole
damn team as a head nod to my mom who is
the greatest person that walks Earth
[Music]
[Applause]
today and I think I think the world
works on stories right I'm very I'm I'm
very passionate about the reason reason
even is a Gary ve is I I want to be
looked up to not because I'm trying to
close a gap but because my mom created
me to not have gaps and I want to close
other people's
gaps and so I think stories matter and I
think a lot of us in the crowd that are
fortunate and we feel good I think the
people that are unhappy are very loud in
the world and I feel like a lot lot of
us that are happy like myself we're not
doing a good enough job of being louder
and I think positivity needs to be
louder and I I challenge the people in
the audience who are in a good place to
share more positivity on social we I
feel like happy people like me tend to
be quiet and be with ourselves and keep
it in our cocoons and I think positivity
needs to be
more um more sharing I think we need to
be
louder we all agree and thank you Gary
one of the most special stories I know
I've never forgotten it since I heard it
and about your mom and actually I want
to invite Dave Basco back on stage we
have a gift oh he's here magic hey Gary
how you doing man Dave how are you
brother it's good to see you I for
anyone that knows uh Gary came into my
class unannounced in
2015 and gave the best 45-minute talk I
have ever heard on entrepreneurship and
mindset it was a master class he
challenged students in the audience he's
like who's really an entrepreneur who's
like really ready to go and like six or
seven people raise their hand he goes I
think you should walk out right now I
think you should drop out of college
walk out and I was just cheering I
wanted someone so badly to just get up
and leave and just like Gary ve told me
but since then Gary you uh you shown up
for us and when when I invited you there
was no hesitation and he wrote back we
show up for our people and that is
something that I will never forgive we
um we had so can't thank you enough for
that thank your mench um before you a
couple uh hours ago we had Pete Carol
here and um the story that you tell
about your mother that you just shared
is one of the most inspiring things I've
ever heard and so we were talking about
it with coach and he said you know we
Gary needs a West Coast team he he also
said you know Pete was fired from the
New York Jets at one by the way I got a
story that you can share with Pete when
Pete was the defensive coordinator for
the New York Jets the jet Jets played
the bills on a Monday night game in 1993
and it was ABC with air that game I was
such a big PE Carol fan he was a kid
back then a real kid he's still a young
dude now but he was a kid kid and I
loved his energy and I snuck in a sign
to the metal ANS that had ABC and the
Jets coach that P Carroll was the
defensive coordinator for his name was
Bruce klet and I had the letters ABC and
it said ask Bruce klet promote Pete
Carroll and Pete was promoted later that
year that was one of the great great
moments of my life I'm a huge Pete guy
and uh but I will not be a Seahawks
fan well you you need a West Coast team
and we're so inspired there's a gift
coming your way if you could show it on
the screen I will not I will burn that
[__]
Gary can you please show the gift that's
on that's very
nice I will say
this I will say this the Jets ripped off
the Seahawks so bad in the Jamal Adams
trade that I feel like I'll take the
gift Gary that's very nice you're you're
the perfect closing to this to start
True North and North on mindset you're
all about mindset this is really what
you preach it's your content and you and
Pete are are two sides of the same yeah
we are yeah we I love I love by the way
by the way on the record I think I had
one or two ation quickly with Coach
through the years I'm a big big big fan
of coach and there's a reason he's been
continuously successful and by the way
he was successful with those Jets he was
the coach when Dan Marino did the fake
spike and we lost a bunch of games late
and firing Pete was one of the great
mistakes the Jets have ever made and I'm
thrilled he was there I'm really
thrilled to be with everybody in the
audience I hope one or two things hit
today and most of all what I'm really
and it's so cool that you brought that
up that moment what I'm most most
hopeful for is there's just one person
in the crowd that will actually act I
know a lot of you almost all of you
heard something that hit cuz I know I'm
speaking human truth I just hope one of
you acts on
it that's what it's about it's only
about practice it's only about practice
let's thank Gary Gary V the best love
you
oh